[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have you ever wondered how your
immune system is able to
recognise and destroy the
apparently infinite number of
pathogens that exist
out there?
Paradoxically, it does this
with a relatively
small number of genes.
These genes are called
immunoglobulins, and one of
them is on Chromosome 14.
So if you imagine this is what
it looks like, that this is
the piece of DNA on Chromosome
14 that codes for the
immunoglobulin, we have the
beginning and the end of the
gene are yellow.
But the interesting part is
the middle, because in the
middle we have lots of these
red component and lots of
these blue and green
components.
These are called the
VDJ components.
And this is the way it is in
the gene as you inherit it
from your parents,
but this isn't a
usable form of the gene.
A correct immunoglobulin
has just one red, one
blue, and one green.
So what needs to happen is
this needs to recombine.
The DNA needs to break and
rejoin with one of the reds
and with one of the blues.
So what this does then is it
generates one of the many
possible combinations of the
immunoglobulin, and it
generates other versions of the
immunoglobulins in other
cells in your immune system.
So the amazing thing about
this system is that it
produces a really huge diversity
of immunoglobulins,
all from one gene.
[MUSIC PLAYING]